all right whoa the name of that love or
gun I can't remember who would neon
phantom oh this no way how many brains
did I guess one poof and a body that I'm
just gonna carry on or other trucker
demo Oh God
oh here we go excuse me just need to
deliver my goods hard swore drew oh it's
like actually horrible would drag your
butt no get back here get back no what
are you doing let me go let me go is
that where the man let go of the let go
awesome sword throw can you kill that I
can't even something wrong with my arms
there we go come on yeah that's more
like it
come on come oh come on come on okay
whoop who's ever extreme mountain biking
whoa yeah so extreme I'm a drink piece
of Mountain Dew
give me your [ __ ] yeah stop FX night or
nothing back here well then you won't
mind if I just backflip into it oh okay
so there actually is nothing back there
Oh try this again my leg but I'm okay
I'm the king of spiked falls ultimate
trolling hi there
complete this course go slow go fast
swing what wait what huh go faster
I'm looking a mad guy you out possibly
you those Jets look awfully foreboding
son neon sword throw wait for screen
nope aha whoa the name of this level i
block my choice like slim dare
the space elevator
hey son what join whoa oh my what does
huh why this isn't a space elevator at
all this is this is less than pow
what what is going on what is that bag
wait a minute
Chinese sucks doesn't seem right this is
a rope swing of all the wrong leveled
would bet on I'm pretty sure they did
the wrong East so we were supposed to be
on this guy so let's give this a try
Oh fail fail fail [ __ ] one more do daddy
boo tsk ha ha I'm like an elegant little
bird floating in sky huh my toes raining
blood okay let me actually grab and grab
onto my dress get escaped my box what is
this some sort of a pickup ha Bastet ha
I'm the greatest Oh sick tricks man like
a boss did uh neon ropes with a long
rope swing Pro what the hell don't look
at me like that I'm a professional ha ha
see the way I slide oh so professionally
oh yeah yeah what am i doing oh oh what
that sick rope swing Pro oh no this lap
bars pushing a little bit on my my
abdominal muscles I'm not fat I just
have a lot of ab na but no more more
muscle I'm putting down as hard luck
and would you want from a youth dooba
coaster it's your problem not mine I
don't know
oh you're stupid Louisville is great
five an Asian Sarah's not here the leap
of faith is here this is this guy's
voice yeah this is me hey there's two
Jersey for fate did not make it out all
right let's try this new at least I'm
loose key oh okay all right I'm going
kid screw you I think I missed one but
screw you
impossible get over the edge oh no it's
impossible
uh-huh my body's ready Pogo equals
survived backwards in my book Laura you
kids that's level said that you needed
100% skill and if I do you think that I
know I tell you tell all the dirty still
all right you can try this again
let's fly over the super jet just our
evil are you kid the judge on pro ball
fall does anything that I'm 100% sure of
is that all jump
yo where's my nubile young boys save
your friend how is your operation wait
what's that God doing with that baby
no what the hell game what the hell Dada
hardcore ball run I'm sorry son but okay
goodbye
close I will not let it be goodbye son
[ __ ]
goodbye son oh we are [ __ ]
goodbye son goodbye son watch the leg
didn't do much extra weight oh no what
is there to go to the No oh my god I was
too fast I didn't touch the name of the
glove organ guys the things that are
coming ah a destroyer
this has been happy wheels highlights
thanks for watching if you like what
your son you want to see more why not
subscribe to my channel want to help the
channel grow leave a like add it to your
favorites or share it with your friends
on Facebook and Twitter thanks again and
as always I will see you in the next
video